I fell 20 feet and broke both my arms it
was a stunt falling off a stack of
chairs like 20 feet and the chairs
didn't fall but I fell day three
day three production
we had 40 more days to go yep and he
just he just carried on he didn't even
stop for a moment he kept working
because if I broke my arms it would have
been a week off for me but then I went
back up a stack of chairs did it again
did okay whatever and then um I went to
the hospital at lunch and then they said
that that's broken that's broken I'm
like okay cool and I went back to work
and I had a screw about going back to
work because I had to Chuck Donuts at
Helms they would just know he would peel
these sort of cast off on rolling and
then action do the same with sort of
floppy spaghetti out he wore a green
kind of green screen casts
that were uh you know that we eventually
painted out in the in the edit keep in
mind this is a man who's done a hundred
Avengers movies
and been fine